[Musique]
voir les enfants beaux dauphins
à qui souhaite une bonne fête nounours
nicolas patron à tous le petit nicolas
c'est demain la saint nicolas mais c
'est tenu qu'il vient bonne fait le nid
collants dont le sol est au pop pop pop
pop aux
[Musique]
syndicats tiendront deux chatons qui
sait olten nicolau
ouais mais sous cette nuit que
saint-nicolas bien et nous avons mis nos
souliers dans la cheminée et notre petit
panier aussi j'y ajoute le cadeau de
nous
bloquer ce que scène on ne voit pas je
le ferai moi-même demain cela fait un
mois n'ont ni mon petit nicolas il faut
être sage les enfants sinon saint
nicolas ne viendra pas ce feuillet vous
savez qui c'est saint nicolas mais bien
sannikov accros des écoliers apportez
moi quelques hommes d'équipage tous
auraient toujours sage comme un petit
mouton je dirais des prières pourrait
voir dépôt contenait venez ça n'est pas
là venez venez saint nicolas venez venez
pas le drame
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça nuit à la patron des écoliers
apportez-moi dépendantes qui bannit je
saurai toujours sage au mas petit me
contredirez
[Musique]
nicolas on peut déjà nicolas
beuque
nicolas
biner me
maintiens que les petits chats kalkar ne
m'en
vinaires le voit l'enjeu le tuant un
long petit coquin ou dodo
terminé jaligny j'attends fait de
bourret
parrainé manas o nuit les petits
endormez vous faites
là j'éteins la lumière
[Musique]
tu crois qu'il va venir ça nicolas bien
sûr c'est mon c'est à moi ce n'est pas
un prenait lé gardien qui faire
[Musique]
volley ball 210 color rulleau partons
vite nounours avec un peu de chance nous
le rencontrerons peut-être dans le ciel
shirts nicolas ça fait si longtemps que
je ne les ai pas vus bonne nuit les
enfants faute de boer
le
oh
[Musique]